i don't eat chicken no more by the way
i'm vegan
oh congrats i mean i think right i don't
know if that's a good thing or not i
feel bad for you
i feel it's a good thing for me i mean
good for you whatever floats your boat
man
because i got now eight too many i'm
from ireland so you ain't too much
chicken
yes bro i don't need that [ __ ] i know
what it taste like yeah
so you have like lemon pepper like like
cauliflower wings yes
i mean this but that's cauliflower it's
not wings just say you have lemon pepper
cauliflower
don't don't say the word wings but they
wings no they're not
bro i'm gonna keep it a book like
they're called it's cauliflower bro but
look though
what about it as a wing let me ask you
this
how does chicken taste like what it like
don't not the sauce
i'm on keto so i eat a lot of
cauliflower in my life at the moment
certainly don't [ __ ] taste like
cauliflower but okay i'm saying though
what folk really like to i think the
seasoning is the sauce and [ __ ] yeah i
like that chicken too i like to bite i
like i
clean the bones but they got [ __ ]
there's like a texture it's the same bro
i had some it's cauliflower
but all right all right forget the
cauliflower here they got some [ __ ]
i forgot what it's called but it it
feels just like chicken like
i just like i'll be going to the [ __ ]
grocery store and they'll have like the
vegan section and it'll say
vegan chicken strips i'm like these
aren't chicken strips you can't get that
[ __ ]
you can't get that [ __ ] that's not it no
what about like impossible burgers
i feel impossible yeah does it taste
like a burger yeah it's
like a matter of fact next time you go
to atlanta go to a place called [ __ ]
vegan
i've heard of [ __ ] vegan get that [ __ ]
i think they use an impossible
i asked somebody where should i go sure
yo you you should go to [ __ ] vegan i
said i should not go to
i'm a [ __ ] vacation i look like going
to a vegan restaurant you slept right
you need to go we went to uh a bunch of
spots though
i feel like we was like yeah atlanta had
some great food man